by the way i just have to ask you really
quickly did you love doing friends was
that so fun because that was like
that was also so fun i absolutely loved
it i was
originally supposed to do three of them
and it turned into nine shows
and uh it's just a nice positive happy
place with great actors
well i loved you in that as well as so
many other roles okay now
tell me about this hashtag 2020 tip
challenge
mr select i read an article in the paper
about my
my dear friend donnie and he left this
twenty two thousand twenty dollar tip
hoping for in the spirit of hoping for a
better 2020.
then i started thinking about it and i
talked to to
jilly and i said i guess we can afford
it i want to do this and she said i
think you should do it
and uh i go to this same restaurant most
of the time
and and they're like family and
everybody's hurting in new york
it's bad so i wrote a little note and
gave him a
two thousand a twenty dollar tip and um
knew it might get around
but i didn't mind it in this case not to
say i'm a magnificent human being but to
say restaurants need help
even if it's twenty dollars and twenty
cents maybe
you can help them out because uh they're
really struggling maybe as hard hit as
any anything in this city so
i love everything you just said and
this hashtag 2020 tip challenge and i
love that you gave the denomination
of options for people because everybody
has something different they can give
that is so fantastic
and it has inspired us here at the show
to pay it forward in honor of you and
donnie and i was wondering
if you would mind joining me in a
surprise father daughter drew gooder
that's what we call them around here
they're a duo making a difference in
their community would you do that with
us
i'm here man okay so uh we like
surprises around here so if it's okay
i'm gonna hide you on zoom and then
bring you back in oh there you go
perfect
okay we'll see you in a minute tom
selleck okay
hello isabella and luca
hi so great to meet you nice to meet you
oh my goodness you're both so lovely
your father and daughter
i love that you're a duo and i see you
standing inside your restaurant
tara lucia vino
perfect thank goodness i really went for
it um
and you guys have been working
tirelessly to support frontline
workers and what inspired you to do that
so it was really all inspired by
an act of generosity from a family
friend of ours um
you know we're obviously in the
restaurant business and when the
pandemic
shut everything down in new york city
and our healthcare workers you know
we're on the front lines battling
battling the virus in the hospitals she
reached out and said i've been reading
what's been going on in the city
um i'd love to help your guys's
restaurants but i'd also love for you to
deliver food to
an emergency room um because she knew
how hard people were working
so on march 19th last year my
parents actually both delivered 40 meals
to the er doctors and nurses at nyu
langone hospital on first avenue
um which is pretty close by actually and
um you know
that you know the reaction from the
doctors and nurses you know they were so
grateful
that's what inspired us to start feed
the front lines and
i had just left college you know i was
kicked off campus i was about to
graduate
um but my i told my friend about the
idea and we built a website in 18 hours
and started collecting
donations um and people were incredibly
generous so that's that's really what
inspired it
i mean luca you must be so proud of your
daughter
i could not have asked for a better
daughter
she's amazing and we have delivered over
170 000 meals
but we brought on other restaurants
restaurants from
all over new york and we've had 35 over
35
restaurant partners so it was not about
carlos vino but was about
sort of trying to keep you know
new york restaurants alive because as
you know it's been
tough it is still very possible well
you're trying to inspire people
and clearly you have now ironically i
hear someone that inspires you
you're a tom selleck fan yes i am
great say hello to mr tom selleck
[Applause]
thanks for the work you're doing
[Applause]
this is incredible i just thought that i
should introduce i was just hanging out
wanting to say hi
oh my gosh so i grew up in italy and uh
i remember
watching my p.i
you know and he was the coolest guy he
is still is the coolest guy out there
and uh no i think my mother was in love
with him you know
yeah we all everybody was and tom
selleck who is such an amazing
human being which is what really makes
us love him
he has this hashtag 2020 tip challenge
and so on on behalf of all of us here at
the show
we wanted to give you the hashtag
and twenty dollar tip that tom and
donnie wahlberg
um have been initiating and of course
we're gonna double that because there's
two of you
and then i'm gonna throw in so we're
definitely going ten thousand here
to just say thank you for everything
that you are doing we all want to help
but sometimes we don't know where to go
so i applaud you for leading the charge
on this
stay willing thank you so much
appreciate it wow this is oh it's so
generous thank you both so much
i am in awe i'm out of money
[Laughter]
and yet tom this is inspired by you and
donnie wahlberg
and isabella and luca you really are
doing something incredible so for more
information about feed the front lines
head to our website the
drewberrymareshow.com
to learn more and get involved yourself
go new york
thank you thank you all right thank you
luca and isabella
and tom thank you so much for coming on
the show today i really appreciate your
time
thank you so much for giving us a
lifetime of such goodness
and blue bloods airs on fridays 10
9 central on cbs
you